mentioned this on my podcast the other
day her name is LTE Montgomery black
woman she had dreadlocks pretty young
lady um she she's very vocal about the
game industry she's no longer working
for double F she mentioned on her
Twitter how working on cyon not 2 was
like difficult on her you know just the
constant crunch or whatever the issues
was working with double her she was in
one of the vidock I think so but yeah
yeah yeah yeah so she's very critical of
the gaming industry every time there's
some layoff she will tweet something um
you know saying pretty much I'm
paraphrasing here but saying pretty much
see see told y'all you know something's
not right with the gameing industry and
um you know I don't know we don't know
what's going to happen